hello Carly what do you have there
they're plastic bags and illegal and the
man hunting them down is South Sudan's
eco-warrior I'm looking for
no I'll magic is on a one-man crusade
against plastics determined to stamp
them out and get them off the streets of
the capital Juba it's not awfully
popular yeah double calendar she hands
over the black plastic bags as others
are being rounded up and arrested mother
or not she too is going to be arrested
but it'll mean losing a day's takings
and she's distraught life is tough here
and plastics just not seen as an
important issue so she's given a second
chance but without the plastic bags her
business relies on when we met Niall he
was in charge of cleaning up the capital
of the world's youngest nation there's a
tenuous ceasefire between fighting
factions so armed guards come with the
territory
all the plastic bag contraband is seized
and locked up in secure units but it's a
mammoth task and the South Sudanese
authorities are up against organized
gangs making huge amounts of money
smuggling in bags from other countries
these lockers are emptied every few days
but South Sudan has a mountain of
challenges maintaining a fragile peace
with warring militia and dealing with
endemic corruption are just two yet this
group led by Nile is determined to do
its bit although their way of disposing
of the bags is likely to cause much
consternation amongst environmentalists
burning plastic releases dangerous
toxins into the atmosphere that is
literally millions of dollars just going
up in flames but they haven't come
anywhere near to smashing any of the
smuggling networks and the dependence
they have on plastics here doesn't look
likely to end anytime soon Alex Crawford
Sky News South Sudan